Ember CLI is recommended by the ember
team as the de facto way of building and
developing a new amber application.
It's incredibly powerful, and
we'll be using it to generate our
ember app, create new template, and
component files, and
maintain and update new routes.
You can do a lot more than
just these tasks though.
So let's see what it can do.
Running ember --help gives us a list
of subcommands with their own set
of options.
There's a lot to scroll through but
we can do just one comment at
a time by using the help flag.
And passing the name of the sub command.
I'm going to clear the screen so
that there's not all this clutter.
Then to see just the new command.
Run ember -- help new.
Ember new is the command we
will use to create a new app.
Notice that running this command
will create a new directory.
I like to keep stuff I work
on in a project's directory.
So when i use ember to
create a new project,
it'll create the app's folder in here.
Let's create our app.
A name is required, so
let's give it the name UdaciMeals.
This command does a number of things.
It creates an Ember app's
default file structure.
Creates an initial commit.
Runs npm install.
And runs bower install.
Installing the dependencies can
take quite a while, so I'm just
going to pause for a second until
it's finished installing everything.
And it's finished.
Let me clear the screen again.
Another thing that Ember CLI
includes is a built-in server.
We don't have to worry about
installing a server or
dealing with some third party code.
This is really awesome.
But the server needs to run
inside of our project, so
we need to move in there.
Running Ember serve
will start the server.
We can view our app at localhost:4200.
Switching to the browser shows us our
Ember app with some starter content.
An entire development server in just
one command, isn't that awesome?
Ember CLI is an amazing tool
that's always in development,
sometimes a bug will pop
up from time to time.
While recording this video
I ran into a bug myself.
There's a story about it
in the instructor notes.
If you have any problems with Ember CLI
check out the project's issues on GitHub
to see if a fix is already in the works.
Or check the forums to see
if what you're running
into has already been solved.